each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
um so it's a pleasure to be welcoming
back Sudipto das who was here as a as an
intern working with us a year ago and
since then he's been been a busy guy
he's got papers published in all the top
database conferences and in several
others co-winner of the best paper award
cider and best runner up at mobile data
management conference and and has more
work coming out in the pipeline
certainly isn't going to have time to
talk about all of that today but but
he's going to tell us about some of his
work on on transactional record
management for database systems thank
you very much Fred for the nice
introduction and thank you all for
coming so as Phil pointed out this is
going to be just a sliver of the work
which I've done in the broad area of
scalable data management so this one
focuses on scalable consistent and
elastic database systems and the context
I'm setting it is for the cloud
platforms so as many of us are aware
like over the past few years but a lot
more and more applications are being
delivered over the web over the network
not only has this front-end change this
has also resulted a change in the
back-end infrastructure what we often
call as cloud computing so in its
simplest form cloud computing is
essentially cloud infrastructure or
services provide or solutions provided
as a service and it's already become a
pretty big business and it's growing and
some of the key factors to the success
are the economies of scale and the
notion of elasticity or pay-per-use kind
of pricing even though on most every
aspect of computing can be provided as a
service three paradigms have evolved as
popular ways of providing cloud service
namely infrastructure as a service
platform as a service to all the way up
to software as a service where your
entire software comes as a package
delivered over the cloud irrespective of
which layer you are using or which
abstraction you are using for the cloud
data
is a central concept and DBMS s form a
mission critical part of mission
critical component of the cloud software
strike they kind of serve petabytes of
data did manage petabytes of data and
more often than not they drive the
revenue of the company as well and
because of the wide variety of
applications that are deployed in the
cloud they often have to deal with a
wide variety of applications themselves
a term which we often refer to as
multi-tenancy if you consider the data
needs of these applications you can
broadly divided into two different
categories on one one hand we have the
OLTP systems which are there to just
serve data your small readwrite
transactions and on the other hand we
have the data analysis systems that
allow for decision support and
intelligence this is obviously a very
like simplified view of the world in
this talk I will be focusing on the
transaction processing systems of the
transaction processing aspect of these
databases so if you think of the
application landscape for this oltp
databases what does it look like it
ranges all the way from social gaming to
rich content to manage the applications
and we have the cloud applications
platforms as well that are growing in
popularity like Windows Azure or app to
Google App Engine and they have an OLTP
database that is sitting behind the
scenes serving all the applications so
as you can see it's pretty rich and
diverse there are a large number of
challenges that need to be solved for
designing such oltp databases in this
talk I just focus on three specific
challenges as we all know that the
amount of data or the my number of
applications that are being served is
growing every day so scale is definitely
a big problem so these systems must be
scalable but because they have they are
oltp they also must ensure that they are
serving transactions efficiently or they
are executing transactions efficiently
elasticity is a big thing in cloud where
it allows for the infrastructure to be
provisioned on demand and we want our
databases that are deployed in the cloud
to be elastic as well that is have the
ability to scale on demand in a live
system and last but not the least when
you have a big system you want it to be
self manageable to reduce the number of
dollars you spend
in getting administrators for the system
so you want intelligence without a human
controller I will get into the details
of each of these challenges so if you
consider the challenge of scalability
there are classically two different
approaches to scalability one approach
is scale up where you throw more more
powerful or high-capacity hardware and
this is a typically used in the
classical enterprise setting where it
was more convenient to scale up the
databases and the relational databases
are one of the popular examples that
likes Caleb because the rich
functionality that the relational
databases support it is easier to scale
them up rather than the other way around
and the key idea here is that you still
have even when you have a bigger
hardware or a more expensive hardware
you still have you limit access to a
single node which is the key for
efficiency and a good performance as
well now obviously this is not a viable
solution for the cloud where you want to
leverage from the commodity hardware or
the economies of scale that can be
leveraged from commodity hardware in
that setting you want to use a cluster
of commodity servers to scale out or
what we say scale out so the idea here
is that you somehow partition your
database divided up into smaller
granules and then spread it up into on a
cluster of servers so one of the systems
that has taken it to the extreme is what
we call the key value stores where they
broke down the database to the smallest
possible granules of CC single key value
pairs or rows and then distributed it
across a cluster of thousands of servers
or even geographies in many cases but in
order to do that what they have done is
to ensure scalability and to ensure the
property that you want to have your
transactions at a single node they have
limited the functionality and guarantees
that that is supported there are a lot
of limitations that are imposed for this
talk I just focus on the aspect that
these key value stores do not provide
support for multi row or multi-step
transactions now why is transactions a
big deal I think many of us in this room
already know that but just to give put
you in context why actually care about
transactions so if you think of a very
simple application like a social network
or social any social application and
there is a friend request that is
accepted
so this results in updating to the
friend lists of the two individual users
if you were in a world where the
database system supported transactions
this is the code you would write as the
application developer so the key idea
here is the simplicity and this is one
of the main reasons why databases have
been so popular over the last few or
last two or three decades on the other
hand if you were writing it on a key
where you store with limited guarantees
this is just a fragment of the code
which you will end up writing do not
even bother reading it because there are
a lot of corner cases that have been
left out here and this is what the
application developer reimplement for
every application it rides so in summary
it is it gets too complicated to write
for the it makes life of the application
developer harder and harder to build on
this these kind of key value stores or
the reduced consistency guarantees so if
you view it as two different axis as
scale out being the vertical axis and
acid transactions being the horizontal
axis on one hand we have the relational
databases that give good functionality
and strong acid transactions but are not
very amenable to scale out they do
provide limited scale out on the other
hand we have key value stores that give
you scale out to probably thousands of
node so the challenge which I want to
address is spanning or bridging the gap
between these two systems because there
is a lot of potential to be leveraged or
a lot of potential to be exploited in
the middle space by providing
transactions at probably not the scale
of thousands but probably at the scale
of tens of nodes which spans a lot of
different types of applications and it
becomes even more critical for cloud
platforms that often cater to a wide
variety of applications as I've already
mentioned elasticity is a key thing in
cloud so compared to classical
enterprise setting where you have a
statically allocated capacity cloud
allows you to provision your systems on
demand so the underlying infrastructure
allows you to scale on demand so we want
the database systems to have this
ability as well so we want to have the
database systems to be elastic as well
as be lightweight in terms of providing
the elasticity elasticity by not
introducing a lot of over
and last but not the least managing
these systems is often a pain why is it
so because as you go to scale failures
become unknown rather than being an
exception so recovering detecting and
recovering from these failures
coordination and synchronization between
a cluster of these nodes how do you
provision these systems how do you do
capacity planning and the laundry list
essentially continues for what you want
to do automated so there is a code from
a famous open source system called
zookeeper that says a large distributed
system is essentially a zoo and that is
why you need a zookeeper for automating
a lot of these guarantees now to add to
it if you consider the cloud platforms
they are inherently multi multi tenant
so there is a conflict between the goals
of the service provider that is trying
to minimize its operating costs as well
as the performance guarantees that are
given to the applications that are
designed and the challenge is how do you
differ design these self managing
systems by minimizing the need for a
human controller in such systems to this
end my dissertation makes the following
contributions to provide transactions at
scale I have designed two different
systems that allow you to scale out on a
cluster of commodity nodes while
providing transactional axis so one of
the systems called elasticity uses a
static partitioning technique while
another system called G store users are
allows you to form the partitions
dynamically on demand to provide
lightweight elasticity I have proposed
two different designs for two common
database architecture one design called
albatross give provides you lightweight
elasticity in a shared storage or a
decoupled storage architecture zafir on
the other hand provides you lightweight
elasticity in a classical shear nothing
database cluster and in the self
manageability front I am currently
working on a design called Pythia that
allows you to do workload
characterization for tenant placement
etc how to automate this kind of this
kind of things in a large database
system for the interest of time in this
talk I just delve deeper into two of
these systems are obviously we can talk
offline about the rest of the papers but
before getting into the depth of the two
different papers
I'd like to spend a couple of minutes to
give an overview of the kind of work
which I have done so as I've already
said this talk and my dissertation
focuses on transaction processing on the
other hand if you consider analytics I
have also worked on a number of projects
to support a different kind of analytics
or Richard analytics for the different
type of data needs and one of the
projects called Ricardo as an intern at
IBM almaden I worked on a project that
allows for statistical models to be
built on terabytes of petabytes of data
essentially it is an integration between
our or a statistics software and Hadoop
as a data management software I've also
worked on a project for
multi-dimensional data analysis to
provide a scalable multi-dimensional
indexed database system to support
location-based services and essentially
this is an architecture that allows you
to ingest a lot of location updates
which are coming from the mobile devices
as well as done analytics online in such
a system so that you can build rich
applications like recommendation systems
on top of these systems in a somewhat
different product project I have also
worked on social network anonymization
that if you want to anonymize the edge
weights in a social graph how do you
anonymize the graphs while preserving
some of the properties on the other hand
I have also been I have also worked on
some of the projects that try to
leverage novel hardware that is
available and see how we can expel a
bridge that infrastructure or the new
hardware to come up with better and more
efficient database architectures so as
an intern last year at MSR I was working
with Phil on the project Haider that
gives a scale-out database architecture
leveraging large amount of flash where
low latency data center networks and
large amounts of RAM that is available
in a different context in the context of
data streaming applications you have
long running queries continuous queries
and in this paper in the courts we were
exploiting how we can leverage
multi-core architectures or the
parallelism inherent to multi-core
architectures we efficiently paralyzed
these continuous queries and the in we
also looked at a problem where we were
looking at the same problem but at a
different hardware which is a
ternary content addressable memory which
is a hardware hash table equivalent to a
hardware hash table so this is kind of
the the work I have done as a PhD
student with different collaborations
now getting back to the main area of
main focus of the talk how do we provide
transactions while scaling out so as
I've already said when you want to scale
out to a large number of nodes you have
to somehow partition the database and
then distribute the partitions across a
cluster of nodes I see a very quiet
audience if there are questions please
interrupt me so I wanted to be more like
interactive okay so getting back to
partitioning there has to be a mechanism
of statically partitioning the databases
and classically what we use is what we
call table level partitioning where you
partition every table individually
independent of each other classical like
typical techniques are range based
partitioning or hash based partition
this makes the system management pretty
easy but the IMP the challenge that
arises is that because the data is not
partitioned the way it is accessed a lot
of transactions end up accessing data
from different partitions often
resulting in distributed transactions
which we all know is pretty expensive so
recently what a trend has come up is to
leverage the data access patterns to
partition the database what we call it
partition the database schema itself or
the groups of tables leveraging the
access patterns and the goal here is to
collocate data items that are frequently
accessed together within the same
transaction so here I have shown two
different approaches one is where you
are limiting the schema by providing a
specific schema structure another is
where you are exploiting the workload
patterns to kind of partitioning so this
is work done at MIT this is work done
work done by me in one of our systems
and a similar kind of schema pattern is
also supported in cloud sequel server as
well as megastore which are other
commercial systems so if you consider
this problem of scaling out where you
have statically partition the database
somehow so that most of your
transactions are within a single
partition this essentially what
aloud is you have made your transaction
processing easier but when you are
scaling out to a big system you have to
deal with all the set of distributed
systems challenges that were listed in
one of the earlier slides and actually I
have proposed designed and implemented a
system called Astra's that charge that
provides one way of solving these
challenges this is a talk in itself but
unfortunately I wouldn't be getting into
the details of this system but we can
definitely talk offline on this and
there are a number of other systems that
were developed concurrently as well as a
set cloud sequel server which was a
system that supports sequel as your and
Microsoft hosted services exchange
hosted archive and this was done at
Microsoft there is a project from google
google megastore that can that powers
the google app engine as well as a
relation condemning prototype from MIT
called relational cloud for this talk I
will focus on a somewhat different
problem where instead of being the
partitions to be statically formed what
happens if you form the partitions
dynamically so let us take a concrete
example that static partition leverages
the idea that somehow the access
patterns partition statically what if
access patterns change and often rapidly
for example there are a bunch of
applications where we observe this
pattern for example online gaming
application or other collaboration based
applications or recently we also came
across scientific computing applications
where you can get this kind of access
patterns I will get into details of one
of these applications later in the
slides as you can see the access
patterns are evolving obviously it is
not amenable to static partitioning as
in we are losing out on the benefit of
statically putting data together by
trying to limit most transactions to a
single node because the access patterns
are changing you end up doing a lot of
distributed transaction so the question
we wanted to answer is how do we get the
benefit of partitioning when accesses do
not statically partition and we propose
a solution which is one of the first
solutions to allow that so let us take
this example of an online multiplayer
game we have a statically partitioned
database somehow doesn't matter how let
us assume that it happens to be the data
items happens to be one of the rows
corresponds to player profiles
here we have a player ID the players
name some kind of dollars associated
with that iron etcetera etcetera now we
have a bunch of players that are part is
predicated partitions and these players
together want to come and play a game
which is online now while the game is in
progress you want to execute
transactions on this one bunch of player
profiles who are part of this game so
ideally you would want to co-locate
these data items together at one node so
that your transactions are local but
there is a problem the thing is that
players move from one game to another
they want to play with some set of
friends and then move to another set of
friends so the they're not the data
items on which you want transactions
change with time similarly players can
try playing different games there are a
lot of games that come up in a social
platform like Facebook they want to move
around between games so essentially
these groups or partitions are dynamic I
will get to that that's a very good
question actually if Dave knows about
how to trick me but in addition if you
are if you're game becomes popular you
also have to deal with the challenge of
dealing with hundreds of thousands of
these concurrent game instances or
groups being deleted groups being formed
so how do you deal with the scale
problem in addition to the dynamic city
so to restate the problem statement what
we want is we want to have transactional
access over groups of data items and we
want to avoid doing distributed
transactions in doing that this is a
pretty hard problem because the
application is not trying to help me so
what I would suggest is I would expose
an abstraction to the application to
help me out what I want is the
applications to declare to me what are
the data items on it on which it wants
transactional axis we call it the key
group abstractions I want the groups to
be small I will get into why I want the
groups to execute a non-trivial number
of transactions as well again I will get
into why and as I said is these groups
can be dynamic and formed on demand so
the applications can form a group as
well as delete a group and if you want
to stretch your imagination to multi Dan
stems you can view the groups to be
dynamically formed tenant databases
where your tenant data is kind of in a
sheer table kind of distribution now how
are we going to do it as I've said
because the application comes in and
says what are the arbitrary set of data
items they can be distributed what I am
going to do is that as the first step I
am going to select one of these data
items as a leader the leader selection
is can be arbitrary or can have a
strategic decision as well and once
there is a leader is selected what the
followers do is the rest of the keys in
the data in the group which are called
followers transfer their ownership to
the leader node so that all the
readwrite access of the data items here
are co-located at one node the key idea
here is that again we are now limiting
the rest of the accesses to the group to
a single node so that transactions can
execute efficiently so yeah conceptually
only the ownership is moved the
readwrite access the data is actually
not moved so i will get into the details
to answer Dave's question is as you have
said that because we are moving access
to one node what happens if groups are
have overlaps if the overlaps are small
they can be co-located at one node but
if overlaps become adversarial obviously
you end up doing a lot of distributed
transactions I am moving some of the
ownership to a single node that is why i
want the groups to be small so that i
can serve them from a single node and in
addition because i am paying a cost
upfront for doing the movement that is
why i want a non-trivial number of
transactions to execute so that I can
amortize the cost over the over the
execution of these transactions I have
again made my life easier by putting
things together at one node so
transaction becomes easier but what i
have done is i have added a dynamics to
the system that this handshake between
the followers and the leaders now have
to be guaranteed to have correctness in
the presence of the different types of
failures that can happen just one
transaction yes that is similar to a
distributed transaction so essentially
what we do is we form a
we execute what we call a group
formation protocol which is similar to a
distributed transaction to do this in a
fault-tolerant way now as I said what
are the challenges the challenge here is
to guarantee the corn that the contract
between the leaders and the followers is
made in the presence of both the leader
as well as the followers failing in the
presence of loss duplicated or reordered
messages within the network as a result
of network failures arising or in the
presence of dynamics of the underlying
system because you have a statically
partition system sitting underneath that
can do its own set of things in a funny
ways you still want to guarantee
correctness in the presence of there and
now that I have brought things together
at one node how do I efficiently execute
acid transactions on this dynamically
formed groups so let us take one at a
time to deal with the first challenge
before do the grouping protocol
essentially what i will give is a very
high level overview of what how we do it
so if you consider the timeline this is
how the leaders time is progressing this
is how the followers time is progressing
at some point in time the application
comes and says hey i want to form a
group or I want transactional access to
the group that is when the leader
execute the handshake between the follow
up with all the followers node by
exchanging these messages once this
handshake completes the ownership as is
at one node so all the group operations
are now local so they are efficient at
some point in time the application says
oh I am done with it I do not really
care about this group anymore so that
there comes a delete request at which
point there is another handshake that
guarantees that the ownership is given
back to the followers and the keys are
filled from from a group now what I have
abstracted here is that all of these
messages can fail here messages can be
lost so essentially we use mechanisms
for timers retransmissions as well to
deal with failed messages what might
also happen is messages can get
reordered or duplicated or be delivered
and after a long period of time so we
use a concept of per group efforts to
detect stale or reordered messages or
not getting into the details of these
the paper has all the details in
addition
nodes can fail as well so what you have
might have noticed here is that we have
a bunch of logging operations that are
happening for all the group group
operations of the messages being
exchanged so this is the log about at
both the leader and the follower that
persistently stores the group
information as well as allows us to
recreate the group information after a
failure so what i can do is that if
somewhere here the group node fails i do
not terminate the group formation it
kind of resumed after failure yes a
crash failure not a malicious one yeah
there is a permanent failure as well so
in that case the log has to be persisted
across a failure so what I realize a
failure where the log can i still have
access to long so one idea is to
replicate the log itself by putting it
in a replicated storage so that way you
can deal with single node failures and
still have log so for folks who are
familiar with database architecture so
this is conceptually similar to locking
the difference here is that instead of
locks being held by a transaction now
the locks are being held by the group
during the lifetime of the group now how
do i efficiently execute transactions
now once everything is at one node
essentially this boils down to an
architecture something like this that
every node has a transaction manager
that deals execute transactions on the
group and there is because the leader
has unique access to the data items I
can aggressively cache the data items at
the leader so there is a cache manager
that caches all the data answering
ravi's questions that is just the cache
of the data the actual data is here with
the followers and all the transaction
updates are local to the cash so how do
I guarantee persistence of these updates
I use a log at the transaction manager
that logs all the transactional updates
so that I can deal with failures of the
transaction manager as well and recover
from the log so the cash is
asynchronously propagated to the
followers so that the followers
eventually get all the updates and there
is a guarantee that before
poop is deleted all updates have
propagated to the group so this way what
you have done is that by paying the cost
of one distributed transaction at the
start of the group the rest of your life
becomes easy and efficient so
essentially you amortize or after
executing a few transactions you kind of
break even and start getting the profits
in terms of implementation how can we
implement it so as a proof of concept i
implemented it on top of a key value
store I chose each base which is an open
source variant of big table so here what
we have is the key value store logic
that is executing on a cluster of
servers and what I add is I added a
grouping middleware on top of it that
has a grouping layer that executes the
group formation and deletion as well as
a transaction manager that execute
transactions on the group and to answer
your question you can put the log in the
distributed storage so this allows the
log to be persistent across failure of
individual nodes so how did we do in
terms of performance so our evaluation
was done again I'm using this prototype
implementation which is about like
10,000 lines of code added in the
middleware layer and we I experimented
using Amazon ec2 to do some scale out
experiments I did an online benchmark a
benchmark which is an online multiplayer
game and on a cluster of a modest
cluster of 10 nodes we were able to
serve about a billion rows which is
about a terabyte of data and with groups
of the size of 100 keys the group
creation latency was somewhere between
10 to 100 millisecond depending on how
you select the groups and how you are
doing and in this cluster of 10 nodes
you are able to serve about 10,000 nodes
on 10,000 groups being concurrently
served on this cluster obviously this is
just a snapshot of the experiment the
paper gets into details of how the
numbers vary on the different parameters
and this is just a view of the same set
of experiments which shows that
depending on how you choose how you end
up implement in implementing the
middleware layer you can implement it
within the key value store or sitting
outside the key value store and
depending on two different distributions
of key selection how does the group
creation latency and the group creation
throughput very
so as you can see this is a distribution
which allows where keys are contiguous
so my implementation can efficiently
batch the group formation to give you
very low-cost group formation while if
you come up with an adversarial
distribution it can obviously get worse
now I shown you a mechanism of executing
transactions and I have briefly
discussed about a mechanism that allows
you to execute transactions in a
scale-out sitting so did you compare the
just round robin partitioning or hash
partition so this is the range
partitioning here so when terms of
transactions per second comments how how
much better are you so very naughty yeah
so the thing is that we don't have an
experimental evaluation for that we are
currently working on the because there
is no distributed transaction
implementation on HBase so I am
currently implementing on that but the
idea here is that the back of the
envelope calculation is that if you are
exactly for the group you have done two
or three transactions you have broken
even because now you have already broken
even for the cost of group formation and
now anything you do is profit for you
that's back of envelope but actually it
might vary because the group formation
is essentially like running a
transaction one is significant okay
one distributed transaction and then
yeah yeah also acted in 214 formation
and one for deletion yeah so do you
deciding when to form a group by the
size of the group you're expecting the
application to know these for you yeah
in the current work yes but in the
future we would like to try to automate
it based on some work load patterns or
using some form of exposing higher-level
semantics so that the applications can
do it declaratively but in the current
setting yes yeah so you in a shared
storage so this we are no we don't but
this implementation happened to lose
that but we don't have anything in the
shared storage so what except for the
log for high availability but what the
the key idea here is that what we are
doing is we are decoupling the
transaction execution from the actual
data storage and allowing you to do a
lightweight reorganization you can view
it as being a shared storage because the
underlying storage itself is shared
across multiple groups but nothing
inherent groups overlap you still see
for instance
not using hoops ago if the group
overlaps are small then yes so you can
stick multiple groups together at one
node but if they overlap like
arbitrarily then obviously this is not a
good solution probably you need
something different ok so now assuming
that we can execute transactions somehow
two different approaches are shown how
do you make the design elastic so that
we have the property which we wanted to
have so what exactly does elasticity
mean in the data based here I will give
a very high-level motivating example so
let us take a simplified view of the
world there is a class of the de set of
application clients that are accessing
the service through a load balancer and
there is a tier of application of the
web server and the database is sitting
at the bottom in this I will consider
the ki will motivate this from more from
the multi-tenancy aspect but it can be
applied to the database partitioning
based approach as well I use a color
coding where the clients have a color
corresponding to the database partition
here or the tenants tenants are color
coded now I put this app I design this
application put it up on facebook it
becomes extremely popular one of my
applications become extremely popular
and there is a surgeon load so if this
infrastructure was deployed on a cloud
what i can do is the application server
TR can easily scale out because very
little state is being shared across them
i would want the same property within
the database which is currently not put
typically not provided is that you would
want to add a new node to the system
migrate over parts of the database in
this case the tenant database so that
you can redistribute the load or balance
the load across the different set of
servers I would also want to do the
reverse process that when the load
decreases I would want to have the
ability to consolidate back as well this
consolidation is critical to optimize
the operating costs in a pay-per-use
infrastructure so as you have said is
seeing essentially elasticity in the
database tier boils down to migrating a
database partition or tenant if you may
in a live system without introducing any
downtime this allows you to optimize the
operating costs as I've said as well
in a multi-tenant system where multiple
tenants are sharing resources between
the of the system resources this is an
effective tool to do online resource
orchestration on demand as the resource
requirements change obviously as you can
see migration is a loaded term because
migration can also be used for as the
database software evolves how do you
migrate data between the different
software's or how how do you migrate
data is the data scheme as the database
schema evolves so the use of my term of
migration in this setting is primarily
for elasticity and is different from
these contexts so one of the simple
solutions or one of the straightforward
solutions which people can easily come
up with is why don't you use vm
migration for database elasticity so how
can we do it one of the approaches is to
have every tenant give its own database
running within a vm and then there is a
hypervisor that shares this vm socratic
different at a single node this is a
valid design supported by the current
state of the art and you can now use vm
migration to migrate things on the fly
however as you have seen and as many of
you know the databases weren't designed
for this kind of operation and if you
are running multiple databases
uncoordinated at the same node god be
with you in terms of performance and
there is a recent paper that shows you
that the performance overhead can be as
much as an order of magnitude both in
terms of performance as well as the
consolidation ratio so what you would
want is you would want multiple
different database partitions to be
resident within a same database process
that gives you somewhat better
performance even I would I'm in my life
I wouldn't want it to the vm to be
sitting here as well but let us consider
it for this scenario now you can use the
vm to migrate the database again but now
what you have lost out is that you have
lost out the ability to do fine grained
load balancing was that a question ok so
what you would ideally want is this
world where you have only the database
process running on bare metal a bunch of
tenants or database partitions sharing
the same database process and above a
model which is called shared process
multi-tenant
in the database literature and you would
want to migrate individual partitions on
demand in a live system so what I am
essentially saying is that what VMs
allow you to do for operating systems i
am going to allow you to do the same
functionality in the database tier so
essentially what you can view this to
being virtualization in the database
tier itself again there is another
straightforward solution that can be
done because databases were designed to
be fault tolerant so essentially what
you can do is that you can stop the
database at thus at the source migrated
over to the destination and then start
solving it as a destination I call it
the stop and copy technique and again
this is can this can be done however it
is expensive why is it expensive because
it results in an unavailability window
and I want to have minimal
unavailability during migration if
possible no unavailability I want to
minimize this metric in addition I want
to also minimize any impact on the
tenant while I am doing migration
migration is done for system management
the tenant should not be aware of it so
I want to minimize the number of failed
requests as well as have minimal impact
on the performance of the transactions
that are executing and in addition from
the systems perspective i also want to
minimize the amount of data that is
transferred as a result of migration
there is some amount of data that needs
to be migrated in that this is the data
on top of that so essentially what i
have said there are two different
approaches of in which databases are
designed one approach which we call the
decoupled storage where the transaction
execution logic is decoupled from the
storage logic there are popular examples
like different examples like the system
in last class which I design gstore
happens to be a similar design as well
project Deuteronomy at microsoft
research as well as Google megastore
form into this category now because
you're persistent data is stored in a
network attached storage while you are
migrating you do not need to migrate the
data so essentially now it boils down to
migrating that execution state of the
database migrate the transactions as
well as migrate the database cash and I
propose this technique alas tras as well
as implemented it on top of a so I
propose this technique albatross which
is implemented on top of a las tres
and this is a paper that would be
presented in the upcoming vldb in a
couple of weeks there is also another
way of designing databases which is the
standard share nothing design where the
persistent data is stored in locally
attached storage here when you are
migrating it is a harder problem because
now you have to move them large amounts
of data as well so how do you guarantee
that you do incur minimal cost during
such migration so are the common
examples of this architecture or sequel
as your relational cloud which is again
the M prototype from MIT and my sequel
also has a clustered offering which is a
similar share nothing cluster and we
propose a technique called z f8 which
was presented recently a cig mod in June
in this talk I'll just focus on the fair
you can welcome to come to vldb to get
into the details of shared nothing
architectures takes equalizer for
example they already have certain
availability guarantees and for that
they already replicate the table right
yeah not necessarily need to yes that's
a very good point and we can as I'll
show we leverage from the replication
but when you are doing elasticity you
don't always have you are trying to add
a new node and you do not have always
have a replica running at that node so I
want a technique that allows you to
definitely migrate even in that setting
but yeah as I as you said replication
can be benefited so why is this a heart
problem I've already said that multiple
time so let us get into the details of
the actual points we we want to migrate
the persistent data base image or do a
persistent image of the data which can
be of the order of gigabytes so how do
you guarantee no downtime while you are
migrating such large amounts of data so
you have to execute transactions while
the data is being migrated now because
it is not an instantaneous process again
there can be failures nodes can fail
during migration both the source and the
destination so how do you guarantee
correctness in the presence of failures
especially transaction atomicity and
durability how do you guarantee that the
transactions executing have the
properties as well as you want to
recover the state of migration if there
is a failure in the middle so that you
do not leave the system as in an
inconsistent state in addition because
you do not want any
downtime transactions would be executing
during migration so how do you guarantee
serializability of these transactions
while you are migrating things on the
fly so that from the tenants perspective
it is normal business from as if nothing
happened so what eric root is what the
way we do it does is that instead of
viewing as migration as one chunk being
migrated we break down migration into a
collection of phases it starts with
migration starts with transfer of
minimal information from the source to
the destination we call this the
wireframe the minimal information
consists of the database schema user
authentication information and another
thing called the index wireframe which I
will get into that again instead of
viewing the entire database to be
migrated as a whole we view a database
as a collection of pages a database
pages which is often the case and we use
the concept of unique page level of
ownership and migration of database
pages on demand from the source to the
destination to allow for zero downtime
there is a phase in migration where we
allow for the both the source and the
destination to concurrently execute
transaction on on it and we show that
how you can you have minimal
transactions in conization and still
guarantee serialize ability for such
transactions and we use mechanisms for
logging and handshaking to guarantee
fault tolerance of the different fault
tolerance as a during the migration as
well so in this talk I will make some
simplifying assumption to limit the
scope I'll assume that transactions
execute at a single node I do not
leverage from replication in for this
technique but I can definitely do that
the paper shows you how to do that and I
would assume that there are some indices
that are used to keep track of pages I
do not allow any structural changes to
the indices during migration the paper
obviously gives up all these assumptions
and gives an extended design that is
more flexible compared to what I will
present in this presentation the stock
yeah
a big tree and I do an update as one of
them I'll get into that that's a very
good point activity there are ways of
tweeted replication which doesn't take
the replica the the original source
offline while doing the replica which
allows you to sort of scan the replica
copy the rapid cup copy the data and
then and then use the LOB to bring it up
the day yeah I wish great with shortens
or perhaps that lemonade
service interruption for that
you've seen the paint you painted the
picture before of the doing the
provocation yes yes it's not it's not
yeah that's a very good point the reason
why we do not use it here is there are
two two reasons one of it is that for
setting up a new replica you incur a lot
of tech pointing overhead that is a lot
of disk i/o and if there is the source
is already overloaded you do not want to
add load to the source and the second is
that as you will see here the
destination starts executing
transactions as soon as you start
migration so you are able to offload
some of the load to the destination
immediately so that allows you to a
better performance but obviously the
exact numbers which vary depending on
work loads so my view of the reader base
is a collection of pages there are a set
of active transactions that are
executing and there is an index that
keeps track of these how what exactly is
in the pages i will use this index to
tag along additional information which
is called which i call as the page
ownership information if a page is at
the conventional use in this talk is
that if a page is white which means this
is the node that owns the page or has
unique read/write access to the page and
if it is grayed out the node has
information about the page but does not
have the data when migration starts you
freeze the index wireframe I will get
into what do you mean by freezing and
migrate over the index wireframe so what
exactly is an index wireframe just to
take a specific case of a B+ tree index
your index wireframe is the internal
nodes of the B+ tree index and your
actual data resides on the database
pages what I mean by freezing the index
is I wouldn't allow any structural
changes to the metadata so I still allow
updates to these individual pages but if
there is an update or an insert that
results in a new page to be inserted
which is then a change in this index
fire flame that is something that is not
allowed during migration it will be
aborted in this setting but there are
simple extensions that can be done again
to deal with that problem so essentially
when I move the mic my grade
the index wireframe this is what the
destination has it has information that
oh there are some database pages but it
does not have the database pages so this
is the state of the destination in what
we call the dual mode and in this mode
that is so basically saying of
vegetables nope eight minutes during
magnets during migration see two inserts
for the same chicken who hate women
because yeah work that transaction yes
that's right with using a big bang trim
command you to relax that require yes it
does and you can also use overflow
buckets with ipsilateral be dangerous
okay so at the destination at the start
of the dual monitor just has the meta
information at this point I allow new
transactions to go to the destination
and while the source is still completing
transactions that are still active or
that are arriving due to steal meta data
that the routing layer now because the
transactions start executing at the
destination without the data now the
data is pulled in on-demand leveraging
the index structure to keep track of
ownership information so let us take for
example that page p3 is being accessed
by a transaction of the destination at
this point the request is sent to the
source and the sense the source does
some synchronization at this point to
ensure that there is this page p3 is not
currently being accessed by any other
transaction and if that is true it
changes the ownership information and
migrates the page over to the
destination so this is the only point in
time where the two nodes synchronized
when executing transactions when and the
concept of unique page ownership allows
us in using this mechanism now what as
soon as the source completes all the
transactions now it just keeps figures
out what are the pages that have still
not been migrated and then
asynchronously pushes them to the
destination and destination keeps
getting on the information but again
since transactions are access executing
at the destination pages can still be
pulled on demand and we show how the
index metadata can be used to detect
duplicates in this setting and guarantee
that you do not mess up the raid away
state and once all the page structures
all the pages have been migrated now the
source can get rid of all the resources
the paper again shows how to get rid of
the log logs as well so that the source
is completely free now and everything
the destination is the sole owner now
because of the simplification which I
did for the sake of the talk there are
these are the following artifacts of
this simplification that I migrated
pages only once once a page is migrated
from the source to the destination it is
never pulled back this allows for
forward progress and quick migration but
what it what it allows about it the
implication is that any transaction that
accesses a page that has been migrated
from the source
must be aborted remember here access is
because i want to give serializability
if i if i can give snapshot isolation
then I can allow deeds as I've said no
structural changes to the index so any
transaction at both the source and the
destination if it results in an
structural change to the index that
would be about it as well and because
the destination pulls the pages on
demand from the source there is a higher
latency for some of the transactions
that are going to the destination in
most of the times it's pulling from the
sources cash so it is not such a big
high latency but there is somewhat
higher latency because of the network
traffic changes we are seeking
transactions at the destination we have
a facebook so far I don't need that I
this is just for simplicity to allow for
merging the indices easier when the
paper we actually talked about an
extension that where we do not need that
actually we don't need that so I think I
am probably running short on time so
I'll just keep on some of the
serializable it is ok ok so essentially
what i have done is that i have just
used a simple synchronization mechanism
so how am I going to do guarantee
serializability during transaction
execution as you can see the dual mode
is the only concern because only only in
the dual mode the to set the two nodes
are executing transactions concurrently
what in the paper we show is that you
can use local predicate locking at the
index level and exclusive page ownership
at the leaf level to ensure that there
are no phantoms during migration we use
strict two-phase locking during normal
transaction execution so to guarantee
that transactions are not low
transactions or locally serializable and
because we use this only once
transaction at the database page
migration essentially what you can see
show is that any transaction at the
destination is ordered after a
conflicting transaction at the source so
there is a strict ordering that is
enforced so this allows you to prevent
loops in your serializing serialization
graphs the
providing you guaranteed serializability
how recovery becomes complicated as well
because now to transaction to nodes are
executing transactions concurrently but
again I use this causal ordering
property between the pages that if there
are two transactions that are
conflicting on a page I just want strict
ordering on them I do not care about
other transactions so when I am moving
pages over from the source to the
destination I also carry over the lock
sequence number so that all transactions
at the destination are ordered after the
source even in the recovery log and
during recovery you just replay
maintaining this order so you are
preserving the conflict order during
recovery as well and how do you recover
so this was transaction recovery by the
way how do you ensure migration recovery
you have to guarantee that because this
there are two nodes changing between
different states you have to guarantee
that they are always in the same state
and there is no confusion on that in the
paper we show how at how you can
atomically transition from one stage of
migration or one phase of migration to
another phase of migration and
essentially we use logging and handshake
protocols for doing this atomic
transition and in addition every page
always has a unique owner in the node
and you can use bookkeeping in the index
level to keep track of this ownership
information even after a failure so in a
simple way you would always log a
migration of a page but that introduces
a lot of i/o as well so in the paper we
show how you can rely on the transaction
semantics to capture this migration
information and make it persistent and
be able to recover that as well so
essentially what we show is that in the
presence of arbitrary repeated failures
we can guarantee updates made to a
database page are consistent failures do
not leave a page without an owner under
both the source and the destination are
in the same migration mode so you can
essentially this extends to the
correctness proof and we also show how
you can guarantee termination and
starvation freedom in the presence of
arbitrary failures as well
superior special case of the data
sharing system actually the it is and
the extension which I didn't talk about
relies on data sharing and global and
local law of managers to exchange the
pages but the app so this is this
becomes a data sharing only during
migration so in terms of implementation
the all the sea or the design was
implemented into in an open-source oltp
database called h2 which provides all
the bells and whistles of classical oltp
database and to implement this we went
and added support for freezing the
indices as well as keeping track of
ownership information this was about six
thousand lines of code hacked in the
database engine we use an open-source
router sequel router to migrate
connections from the source to the
destination as a result of migration how
did we do in terms of performance we
evaluated it using a car using an
open-source micro benchmark we adopted
the Yahoo cloud serving benchmark to add
transactions and very the different
parameters of the workload depending on
the database size or the workload which
is executing the vanilla technique which
is stopped and copy allows you results
in three two eight seconds where a
database is unavailable this is for this
very small database about like 200
megabytes or something as you make the
database bigger this unavailability
window becomes longer and locker what
you have to notice that during this
period you can only run the database in
read-only mode so any update transaction
has to be has to abort during migration
on the other hand Zephie does not result
in any downtime because at any point in
time either the source or the
destination is executing transactions in
terms of the failed operations because
stop and copy has to fail all updates it
results in about hundreds to thousands
of operations failing during migration
again depending on the workload these
numbers vary on the other hand Zephie
results in and the simple prototype of
the fail results in an orders of
magnitude for your field operations and
the paper we show how you can guarantee
zero transaction loss but we do not have
an implementation for that yet so even
even though
simple implementation is orders of
magnitude better in that setting so the
failures is because of the inserts so if
we run a adversarial workload with all a
lot of inserts and whenever there is a
change in the index structure that
results in a failure some transactions
may get sent to the wrong machine I had
a source yes but but the source as long
as the store source is still active it
can stands out those transactions but if
they get IC so yeah the board of the
transaction then redirecting to the
entirety it is not consider I know in
this number so transaction refers to
engages one is it the sorcerer has been
migrated as we will the transit know
that transaction will fail so you want
to a distributed ngayon so the car or
what all across my work the idea is to
avoid distributed transactions wherever
possible but there is an extension that
does that actually use a shared lock
manager for getting the pages in the
benchmark you ran so I is a yahoo cloud
serving benchmark with modified support
for transactions multi-table operations
and client sessions so Yahoo cloud
serving benchmark was a key value store
benchmark for key value stores which
obviously does not have any transactions
so what civil in character is what
fraction of the transactions had
multi-page
every transaction required a multi-page
axis and every transaction was multi
operation default was ten you can vary
number of operations within a
transaction we also looked at like 25-30
operation transactions as well so all of
these parameters were varied during the
experiments yes oh yeah oh your thing is
gonna fool pages on so yeah essentially
huge it surely yes but in practice with
in terms of that because what happens is
that most of the trap pages that are
accessed at the destination during the
pool phase are often in the cache just
the reason for locality and then the
final phase is just a copy through the
disk so in theory it can be bad but not
in not in practice for at least the
workloads we did so in terms of
operational overhead we show that the
operational overhead resulting in the as
a result of this migration is very low
of the odd between ten to fifteen
percent increased latency during
migration so this is a number a graph
that shows you how the number of failed
operations increase as you increase the
load yeah please avoid it if you
actually take the most multi-tenancy
kind
the system is already loaded because you
know you are actually trying to scale on
so i think so i think i'm the context
there any increase in the operational go
ahead I mean the time of the migration
is kind of very critical
so I'm done any comparative study space
so the thing is that I agree to it but
if you wouldn't have migrated you would
do worse because your source is already
overloaded so that is the argument
against it and that is one of the
reasons why used with this we use this
technique that immediately you offload
the load to the destination and the
destination starts catching up and
whatever load you do is just for
fetching the pages on demand is the
source already overloaded the source a
scale of the migration because you gave
out because of page for this nation yeah
then you are to overload to you that's
three yes so the that's a that's a good
point as well so the idea here is that I
haven't talked about the controller
level so that there is a controller that
is sitting on top of these things so it
is the responsibility of the controller
to start migration at least when is
there when there is some room left to
migrate if it is already too late you
are one hundred percent overloaded tough
luck there is there is you have already
screwed up your system there is none
migration wouldn't help you so typically
like when you are getting close to being
over booked that's when you initiate
migration that's part of the
controller's responsibility but as I
said that it is a very low overhead on
the source it's just fetching pages and
not executing the transactions if it
were executing transactions it would
have been even more in the mess said so
in terms of field operations here as you
are increasing the load on the system as
you can see the stop and copy technique
the rate of increase is much higher for
a compared to the Cepheid technique not
only is this an order of magnitude
better the rate of increase is also much
higher just to give you an example the
slope of the saffir curve is 0 point 48
whereas that for stop and copy is 8.4
which shows that it this technique is
more robust to deal with different
variations of the load and allows you to
do migration even when the load has is
higher on the source
broadly or up turning medications down
we directly this is at the beams they
figure with much much yes that is true
as well but then they also will have an
impact on the latency of the executing
transactions as well yes yeah but you
still have to abort transactions that
are active at the source so this is a
slope of a line if you fit a line here
on the graph as well as on this graph so
this is the slope of that line is at the
slope of the line across the tops those
yellow Mars is a point for it's like
when you double the number of
transactions you less the double the
height yeah it seems to me to be a slow
so the Chanel's everyone is so this is
basically the slope measure for okay so
this is the slope measure of the angle
which is being projected here in radians
okay so the thing is that what sorry no
I'm sorry sorry sorry I messed up witcha
it's me remember I think it is the I am
sorry I do not remember the exact
measure but I think it is either the
angle or the tangent of the angle which
is reported here but I can look back
into the paper ends yeah yeah
it's really hard to read that McCracken
yeah that's what that's why we added
this information into this graph itself
so I'll have to get back to the paper to
figure out what is what is the exact
measure we did not arrange it ya know so
you see that the increase is much lower
here compared to the increase which is
here so this is the angle of the line
which is drawn my friend like me sorry
does everyone but the stop and copy it's
going to 600 to 1000 over from spreading
transactions per second so we double the
number of transactions are you less than
double the number of failed transactions
that's a slope less than one
anyway okay sorry about that I yeah okay
it's just like six
so stepping back in terms of the overall
vision we want we started off with a
system where we wanted to have scale out
while executing transactions we wanted
to have elasticity as well while
executing transactions so my
dissertation proposes major enabling
technologies to solve these specific
challenges specifically I propose a
design for a scalable distributed data
database infrastructure this is one of
the first few techniques there are a
bunch of things that were also designed
concurrently but this is also one of the
first few techniques in this area as
shown how to execute transactions
efficiently for partitions that are
dynamically formed and this is again the
only technique which I know of that has
been published that allows that and I
have also shown two different I have
also shown two different techniques to
allow for live database migration or
lightweight elasticity again to the best
of my knowledge this these are the only
two published solutions I know there are
some things that are cooking but they
haven't been published yet from the
other groups as well and what I would
also like to point out is that all of
these images designs were implemented in
real systems as well as evaluated to
show effectiveness in terms of related
work i have already covered most of it
scattered throughout the presentation in
for transactions and scale out i
leverage from lot of work over the last
thirty 30 years or so which i didn't put
up here in terms of the state systems
that are being concurrently developed is
the cloud sequel server which was from
microsoft megastore deuteronomy
relational cloud percolator was a system
from google which is forms the basis for
their new index indexing mechanism and
this is a system that does distributed
transactions actually but it is a
different application domain not high
performance transactions and obviously
we have haider as well from microsoft
research and again the list is also this
is an incompletely is just a snapshot in
terms of elasticity and migration we
just have vm migration which is
currently known nothing published
nothing in the published literature in
terms of future directions again
space is very rich and this is
definitely not the end of the story as
try to list some of the problems which I
have the background and I feel are
relevant in the next few and the
upcoming years is I just scratched on
the surface for a self managing
controller for multi tenant system and I
believe it's a very important area to
pursue given that there is enough scope
there where you have a large distributed
system you have no idea what it's doing
trying to get a good understanding of it
and trying to automate the management of
such system such as placement of tenants
resource orchestration online profiling
and how would you would update your
models online as well this is a very
important area of research which I I
want to pursue as well another is novel
data management architectures on one end
we have the hardware which is
continuously improving we have phase
change memory is coming in we have F pgs
we can have GPUs how can we build in
bring this hardware into the database
architecture and come up with more
efficient implementations or more
efficient database architectures and
another thing which I want also want to
point out is the current is a need for
convergence of transaction systems and
analysis systems not our warehouse but
just the ability to provide real-time
intelligence in a system that is getting
all the updates this is extremely
critical for a lot of the applications
that are coming in where as soon as you
see an in the behavior or change in an
update you want to react fast in real
time so this is something which I what
are the right architectures in this
model and how can you build this such
architectures this is another area of
area of interest for me and another
thing which has getting a lot of
popularity is what we call crowdsourcing
or putting the human in the loop I do
not want to propose new crowd sourcing
solutions but for a lot of these
problems I can leverage what a lot of
crowd sourcing solutions as well for
example when we are dealing with
convergence of multiple sources of data
entity resolution becomes a big issue
data integration also becomes a big
issue how can we leverage cheap human
labor to solve some of these hard
problems which we encountered in this
system
to help us out in solving some of these
heart problems so this brings us to the
end of my talk I would like to thank you
everyone for attending this talk and i
will also like to thank all my
collaborators i've had the wonderful
fortune to collaborate with a lot a
large number of great researchers and
specifically thank my advisors divya
grovel and Amidala body without whose
contribution I wouldn't be standing here
and I'd like to open it up for more
questions because in the migration
essentially it is compared to the over
the traditional
it's just working on different
granularity tackler competitive it it
also means that it requires a Bose the
destination and then source just same
physical inner structure yes at askari
also means that it has more competition
you haven't considered about the skin
watch changes they didn't know
diffraction now if you consider what at
those values it will get much book yeah
yeah so I agreed to that and this is one
of the disclaimers I put up front that I
am NOT considering it for this paper
remember software solutions out this doc
she can be mirroring the drop it's what
has a database table it's already very
welcome yeah yeah it obviously with you
the more features you want to proper
proposed that it definitely increases
the complexity as well I don't know if
it well it was a question or a comment
okay beauty yeah also yeah because
there's a publicity yes so the thing is
that what we were trying to solve is we
are trying to solve more of a research
question is how do you guarantee no
downtime the log shipping protocols
actually results in some period of
unavailability so actually if I didn't
talk about albatross that uses a variant
of this log shipping protocol to migrate
your database cash as well as the state
of active transactions as well this is
just a migration scenario they're not a
replication scenario if you're thinking
you start talking about the database
mirroring now you can't just lively say
there's going to be no schema changes
no other structural changes because
you're going to be running this for a
long period here he's only doing the
migration for a relatively short period
to shut down schema modifications during
migration seems like it would be not if
not big not not big inconvenience in my
group es image is about after that is
about the index indexes or even because
of what reduction is not just touching
one day and one image here we touch with
many other other pages yeah yeah I have
definitional question we still support
those kind of transactions the thing is
that only during as Phil pointed out
only during the short duration of
migration some of these operations
become expensive and I the claim here is
that you pay a cost in terms of latency
but you don't incur any on availability
and that is what it is yeah did you
check how much you either he forgives me
they'd like to see has not be available
okay sometimes we'll be back side
although guys the Vice please enter me
what is the difference because if
Yorkers are coming in and I'm to
increase the pH and then you go to get
the pledge to the source and we applied
if you fetch everything in once the next
question come it is already there
otherwise they're all the time I have to
request the data request it's not all
the time it's just for the window and
what I am trying to say some of the
experiments have shown its of the order
of few seconds that is the window while
the source is finishing up their active
transactions and the destination has
started executing transactions I am not
running in this mode forever for the
rest of my life it's just for the small
window the benefit here is that
obviously I can definitely add keep on
adding features but that complicates the
design I wanted to show that using a
very simple design you can still
guarantee a bunch of properties so that
was the main thing which we wanted to
show here and the period of restriction
which we involved is also very short of
the order of even milliseconds for some
of the cases I just given one snapshot
of the total migration time
I actually other indexes are on vacation
so you are actually trying to transfer
the logical structure of the yes yeah
and when you are inserting the page or
inserting the index so the index the way
it is the wireframe copies that you take
an intention lock on the root of the
index and that kind of prevents or any
update locks they are being taken of any
changes being done in the internal nodes
but the index wire frame is still there
but both the source and the destination
whenever there is an insert at the
source or the destination it goes
through all the index structures and
figures out what is the page the actual
insert would be if it figures out that
there is a going to be a page split that
is where it supported if the page insert
can get into the page it is allowed
basically we understand correctly you
will trying to recreate the index and
age Paige be champion is very much more
advice in terms of performance because
at the destination you're trying to
insert one page and you are actually
trying to recreate your index I am NOT
recreating my index it is just copied
once once at a at the start of migration
and the rest is just the freezing of
index is mainly to make my bookkeeping
easier I can allow changes to the index
but then merging with the index of the
source and destination becomes expensive
so this is a trade off more of a design
trade-off rather than a performance
thing or something limiting which I
would say yep the focus on transactions
on immigration what about the long
running queries that's a very good
question that I think I haven't right
that's the short answer but it's it's
harder for that because the thing is
that a lot of transactional workloads
often fit in memory so you you are not
when you are fetching pages from the
destination most of the times it happens
to be in memory but with OLAP or other
analytics queries it's often like a lot
of scans so that further increases the
overhead of migration but they're fit
definitely that is an area of future
work is an important area as well
because you want to have diversity
ok